Vanessa Bryant Saturday would have been
the couple's 19th wedding anniversary
and Friday Kobe and his daughter Gigi
received an emotional tribute Kobe and
Gigi loved the WNBA this is a sweatshirt
the day before her anniversary a tearful
Vanessa celebrated Gigi after she was an
honorary pick in the WNBA Draft hours
later Vanessa posted this photo saying
my king my heart I miss you I wish you
were here to hold me in your arms
tell us how romantic is Kobe very first
anniversary last weekend it was so great
so special love has made me a romantic
guy a source tells us the weekend was
tough for Vanessa every day is still a
challenge Kobe is all she's ever known
but in times like this she's thankful to
have her family and friends we try to do
is just just be who we are love each
other love our family and just keep one
foot in front of the other keep moving
basketball legend Michael Jordan also
devastated by Kobe's tragic death who
can forget his tearful eulogy at Kobe
and Gigi's memorial when Kobe Bryant
died a piece of me died Kobe is one of
the stars who sat down to talk about MJ
in the new ESPN docu-series the last
dance at any cost the series features
never-before-seen moments of the icon
you guys not allowed just kidding
but Michael warns quote when you see the
footage you're going to think that I'm a
horrible guy of course et has spent more
than 30 years with the legend worth an
estimated 2.1 billion dollars as you can
see this is one of my Nike posters that
took me forever to do my arena Marina is
basketball quick
[Music]